schmeckt mir nicht klar kommt sorry rat
seien vier von zehn matches gehabt und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video habe hatte ich hoffe natürlich
euch geht es gut mir auf sie haben
gerade früh am morgen ich habe extra
nächste frühstück weil ich letztes mal
den dokumenten ist alex macht doch bitte
mal alle schoko oder nuss nougat bieten
wie man es im wallis nougat alle nuss
nougat brotaufstriche aus dem supermarkt
ich war gestern abend noch unterwegs ich
war hier ich kann es ja sagen ich von
ihrem leben
da mache ich noch bei aldi und lidl also
bei drei verschiedenen und haben
ordentlich eingekauft wir haben
insgesamt acht verschiedene zur auswahl
wovon ich bis jetzt nur zwei in meinem
leben probiert habe also nutella es sich
halt gerne mal und früher bei freunden
gab es auch manchmal dieses nusplingen
kennst du das also ist ja so dass zwei
bekanntesten motocross da wie noch nie
gehört ist desto höher ist das new
yorker aber habe ich vorher noch nie
gehört keine ahnung auf jeden fall
frühstücken jetzt praktisch vor der
kamera und testen alle sorten die wir
dann gekauft habe ganz wichtig wir haben
gerade hier so ein bisschen aufbauen
also das sofa steht jetzt da die
kaffeemaschine steht hier also wir haben
jetzt ein bisschen mehr platz und videos
zu drehen ist eigentlich ganz neu ist
der stuhl steht hier also perfekt um
platz zu sparen nicht genau dann habe
ich gerade noch einen parkett gemacht
von schneider das jetzt mal dann setzen
wir uns wenn also komischerweise nur
toka steht hier schon jetzt was auch in
nachhaltige der tüte sehr guter letzt ja
also ich benutze immer eine tüte aus
stoff ja wir behandeln naja gut habe ich
noch nie in meinem ganzen leben was von
gehört dann haben wir hier habe ich ja
schon gesagt - fliegt man muss sagen
also aber ist von der gleichen marke ja
stimmt auf dem zucker nuss-nougat-creme
mandeln oder creme habe ich jetzt durch
doch egal
zählen wir es trotzdem dazu oder kannst
ja bewertet dann haben wir für unsere
veganen freunde bionaz dass hier mal
glaube ich sogar das teuerste falls mich
jetzt nicht ihre dunkle cacau creme
stand auch dabei habe ich auch mal
mitgenommen dann hier nochmal vegane
nuss-nougat-creme weißt du was jetzt
kommt meine lieblingsmarke nein gut da
dass wir auf jeden fall hat günstigste 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 und nutella fehlt noch die
habe ich jetzt aber nicht neu gekauft
nutella der brotaufstrich für ein
besseres politischen kennt ja jeder
da würde ich sagen wir fangen wie immer
an für alle dieses konzept dieser videos
noch nicht kennen also ist jetzt 105
also das ist jetzt schon der fünfte teil
dieses formates wir haben alle produkte
die werden immer probiert und dann von
eins bis zehn bewertet je nach geschmack
dann haben wir am ende einen gewinner
ein verlierer und ihr könnt auch wie
immer in die kommentare schreiben was
ihr davon am liebsten ist oder was bei
euch zuhause gibt das lese ich mir mal
durch weil sie nicht die fans
interessant was die leute so essen und
ich würde sagen wir starten hier aus mit
donnelly das bin ich mal gespannt und
das ist halt sogar vegan und der zwölf
produkte auf jeden fall da trieb schon
mal richtig gut
also ich würde jetzt sagen das riecht
ganz leicht anders als nutella ich habe
den geruch von nutella im kopf aber es
riecht lecker also ich finde wirklich
mal gespannt so also ich würde sagen sie
schon mal nicht schlecht aus man nimmt
immer weinkeller ist das ganz wichtig
nimmt sich halt mal ein bisschen zu viel
als zu wenig das schmeckt halt total
schokolade also richtig fragt weise bin
ich dann in schokolade alles mit nutella
schmeckt bin ich noch so richtig nach
nuss nougat creme und das hier schmeckt
nach geschmolzener schokolade also ist
nicht schlecht aber ist schon krass
intensiv also auf jeden fall erkannt
kann man super essen
es fällt mir alle
es würden morgen zu sehr vielleicht ich
weiß nicht ob ich das verstehen von zu
sehr nach einfach geschmolzener
schokolade
deswegen würde ich hier mal anfangen mit
kommt wir sagen einfach mal weiß dass
erstes tut mir leid und ich leider nur 7
von 10 punkten
unser gespannt ob mich die anderen mehr
überraschen sieben von zehn machen wir
mal weiter hier mit nuss blieb wie schon
eben gesagt das habe ich früher ab und
zu mal gegessen weil bei uns zu hause
gab es eigentlich meistens nur teller
deswegen so was hatten wir nicht zu
hause einfach mal meinen papa das auch
nicht machte aber ich glaube das ist so
der zweit erfolgreichste nuss nougat
brotaufstrich nach dem teller in
deutschland wir machen das jetzt einfach
mal so in dem wir hier ein
also ich brauche da mehr von man kann
ich das gar nicht richtig schmecken
ich hatte irgendwie für die echten
vermeintlich so künstlich sogar ist
irgendwie so ein komischer geschmack bei
was man natürlich dazu sagen kann wenn
man das eine woche lang jeden morgen ist
hier will man sich mehr dran aber ich
finde es kommt nicht an den geschmack
von der nutella dran
jetzt werden einige von euch natürlich
wiederum hören und sagen ja du bist ja
voll voreingenommen daran weil gewalt
nutella am liebsten ist da kann ich auch
nichts gegen machen vielleicht lassen
wir dann am ende aus der wertung raus
aber die sie hat mich nicht überzeugt
deswegen gibt es dafür auf jeden fall
nur blieb gemeinde 6
als nächstes nehmen wir dann hier einmal
dieses bell mandl
also das ist kein nuss nougat aufstrich
sondern ein mangel nougat aufstrich
wobei ich hier sagen würde wir nehmen es
trotzdem mit rein hat er schon irgendwas
mit lukas zu tun und deswegen passt dass
auf jeden fall mal gucken auch anderen
unterschied nicht weil ich da keinen
unterschied
also ich bin gespannt es ist auf jeden
fall ein bisschen flüssiger als der
nospa aufstrich schmeckt mir nicht mehr
kommt sorry ich hab so ein
vier von zehn 100 recht nicht meiner
meinung nach nichts schmeckt schreibt
gerne in die kommentare aber ich mache
aber nichts anfangen
also wenn ich das jeden morgen zum
frühstück essen würde wären wir auf
jeden fall die ersten zwei stunden vom
tag schlecht wobei die noch in ordnung
war
jetzt kommen wir hier auch ein fairtrade
produkt von rewe dunkler cacau cremen
ich denke mal das ist so teuer weiß und
wer vielleicht es also muss man ganz
klar so sagen das reicht hatten wir ja
hier ihr glaube ich auch sehr hochwertig
verpackt
also hier bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
vielleicht wäre das ja in zukunft meine
heißt liegt nutella verdrängen
kurz darauf habe ihr habt mir immer
diese dosen aufgemacht das team mit dem
fingernagel einfach so rum wie hast du
es gemacht ja das top4 wird sie gern
messer reinzuhauen ich habe immer so
gemacht
das ist doch dass das ist das langweilig
warum
ach so ja klar das war früher wir uns
auch mal so da gab es immer ärger
neulich musste ich kurz vor ihren ich
habe mich leider vertan
das gab sogar nur 19 90 euro kostet das
ja 399 gekostet und das jahr 299
und das hier war dass wir mit 17 schon
gesagt gut aber ich bin trotzdem mal
gespannt ob es mir schmecken wird
vor ort
das ist finde ich das problem also wir
haben hier ganz großes problem
weißt du was weißt du was das problem
ist das problem ist mal drauf hätte ich
weiß das problem ist ich muss noch bis
ich dann dass das problem das problem
ist für viele dieser brotaufstriche
schmecken irgendwie so als würde ich
erst zum frühstücken brötchen essen wird
er seine schokolade drauf klatschen und
einmal abreißen so schmeckt das nicht
dazu merkt nicht also mir schmeckt das
hier viel zu mächtig viel zu kassen ab
schokolade und nougat was auch immer das
war ich nicht also ich muss dir leider
auch sagen würde ich nie im leben zum
frühstück essen lag ihr sogar einer
ähnlichen preis kategorie wie nutella
ich glaube dass jetzt 30 40 cent teurer
in dieser größe und das ist sogar mehr
drin aber muss ich sagen gibt nur 14
punkte tut mir leid wirklich nur habe
ich immer gesagt wenn du so weiter
machst hast du irgendwann diabetes habe
ich noch nicht ok also die ersten klaren
weg machen wir mal weiter mit nur ca
also das ist ja das sollten wir mal so
machen so probieren
hast du auch manchmal früher wenn du
irgendwie wenn wir so richtig lust auf
schokolade soll löffeln und einmal durch
die nutella nicht okay okay also juli
hinter der kamera meinte not.fse lecker
meint deswegen wir schauen wie man die
auch gut geht kann da nicht mit diesem
hier vergleichen
das schmeckt wie so ein brotaufstrich
der auch ein brotaufstrichs alles
schmeckt winken tabu doch nicht so
intensiv aber trotzdem lecker deswegen
gibt's familie
neun von zehn punkte kannst du schreiben
mama weiter mit dem zweitteuersten und
zeugen haben aber es im mund bio
nuss-nougat-creme 299 400 gramm
okay was haben wir hier 450 kommen sogar
und hier 200 gramm also schon
unterschied
also ich bin mal gespannt ob ich diese
ministerin überzeugt hatte konsistenz
muss man jetzt schon sagen mein blick
fällt schon alles ne also tut mir leid
wie sag ich immer ich möchte meinen fuß
tut mir echt leid aber das schmeckt mir
nicht
von 10 tut mir leid jährlich drei
funktionen ist es nicht aber nur vier
von zehn
aber ich sage mal so könnte man
vielleicht mit ausreichend für titel und
jetzt bin ich eigentlich mal richtig
gespannt weil jetzt kommen wir zu einer
lieblingsmarke ich sag's nicht lustig
und wieder muss ich das übernehmen
willkommen zu meiner lieblings marke
nein und hier habe ich auch schon sehr
auf die schrauben gemacht das ist immer
sehr günstig ist aber trotzdem gut
schmecken kann
deswegen bin ich sehr gespannt auf
diesen brotaufstrich von so leute
letschkow ist nichts also das ist ein
stückchen drin so ganz kleine weiße
stets darauf dass die kindern sind nein
das ist wahrscheinlich noch von der agl
muss also die ist nicht ganz weiß hier
ganz also man schmeckt so ganz kleine
ich würde jetzt malz haselnuss stückchen
definieren da drin
tut mir leid allein schon deswegen drei
von zehn wissen wieviel harten stückchen
sollen rein
doppelpunkt ja gut er muss aber erst
kommt noch niemand ist doch okay und
dann kommen wir zu guter letzt zum teil
der marke die mit abstand in deutschland
am erfolgreichsten ist auf diesem gebiet
aber noch nie gegessen vor
ich weiß dass wieder ein bisschen ärger
aber vom geschmack ja ich muss er nicht
sein
da übertrifft nichts anderes dass es
halt immer so es kann bei jeder auch
daran liegen weil ich das gewohnt bin
seit seitdem ich klein bin jetzt kommt
das große aber es ist ziemlich teuer
besonders zahlen von schirmer 250 oder
so und hierfür habe ich gerade mal einen
euro oder 1 20 bezahlt deswegen kann ich
diese mir auch keine zehn punkte geben
sondern gibt auch 19
und dann haben wir hier einen
gleichstand das ist ja oft so nett oder
also dieses not-op wie du schon gesagt
hast das gibt's bei ihm kann ich jedem
von euch empfehlen super produkt
schmeckt lecker kann man so kann man
entspannen essen morgens nutella ist
natürlich vom geschmack ja noch ein
kleines bisschen besser
leute ich würde sagen ihr schreibt
wieder mal produkt in die kommentare die
als nächstes in diese folgenreiche
sollen irgendwelche sachen aus dem
supermarkt von denen ich mal alle
möglichen testen soll
abonniert den kanal activity glocke und
jackman ist ab 30 alex w da ist was von
mir wir sehen uns morgen um 19 uhr
du hast noch was zu melden nicht also
leute das war
haut rein